there is something you can do
that is better than anyone else and your
job is to find it
if you can have anything in the world
barring all obstacles
what would this be
i love that you started with that
question
for me right now it would be
i would like the book to help
i would like this book that i've written
to help that's why i wrote it
and i would like it to help people uh
find their own point of view
their own artistry
what it is they want to do in the world
i think we're lost
i think we're we're experiencing some
very very difficult times
and i think
time it's very loud
it's very loud right now we're being
bombarded even though we're in our homes
because of the pandemic we are still you
know being bombarded with
with media and internet and social media
and
you know we're lost as to what to do
with our time
um
education is a little sad right now you
know they've taken arts out of school
this is a very dangerous thing this is
not just
a light thing to take arts out of school
this is not just a oh we don't have
enough money so there's no art so you do
those outside of the school art is the
most important thing because it teaches
imagination
you know art is about imagination and
without imagination we have no future
you know this is why
the artists have always been the ones to
lead us into
you know uh better waters or the future
or the evolution of mankind or a higher
way or a higher calling it's always been
the artists
so if you take arts out of school you're
not supporting artists you're not
supporting the people who are going to
teach us
you know how
how to live
so
my thing is okay well let's find the
artist in everyone then if we're not
going to just bring out the
michelangelo's forget them maybe it's
not the time right now we don't have any
michelangelo's we don't have any
beetles we don't have anything in music
literature i don't see this new wave
of art arriving
so let's bring it out in everyone
you know i was raised in i mean i was
in the 70s
we had the painting evolution
it was incredible with jasper johns and
bob rosenberg and you know we had gone
from
from
one kind of painting to another
and uh i was raised with these guys
at the dining room table
and i would study them
and
they you know they just had their own
way of looking at things
the idea was to
see
but to see in your own way to see with
your own eyes to find something for
yourself so you know in the book i like
to talk about negative space because we
don't think about looking at negative
space but that's a great example you
know when you look at a tree
we're educated
to look at a tree in the same way
there's the branch there are the leaves
there's the trunk
artists look at the tree they look at
the negative space they look at the
space between the leaves they look at
the space between the branches
you can even
do an exercise where you paint that
spate you just do the space and then the
picture arrives
so these are things that stimulate the
imagination
this is why when we have art in school
we stimulate the imagination
this is very important
otherwise we follow anything we buy
anything right now we're just you know
oh i think i should look like kim
kardashian i need to look like this one
like oh i need to buy these things
because that's very very hip i need to
buy the right sneakers i mean people are
spending 300 sneakers probably more i
don't know
but it's absurd really
why is that one of the central questions
in your life
this
if you could have anything
okay
well
my father asked me that question
uh
actually i think the first time he asked
it of me i was uh a very naughty
teenager i was a very angry teenager
i'll probably get into that at another
time but
uh my mother sent me to live with my
father in california because she said
i'm done with her she's 14 and helen
wilson do something with this kid
and so i went to with my father
and he lived on the beach in tapanga
when there were houses on the beach in
papanga which was i can't even tell you
how fantastic that was
and
he
wasn't very present when i was a child
because he was an actor and he was in
california working started out on
broadway but then they took all those
guys to california because it was the
50s and television exploded and so he
came out here to work so i i didn't have
a sense of him he i had this sort of
formal relationship with him
but i came and i was in trouble and he
kind of took a look at that and he said
you know josie
if you could have anything in the world
barring all obstacles
what would that be
and i said when i want to live at the
beach here with you and i don't want to
go to boarding school i don't want to go
to private school and i don't want to do
i just want to live at the beach with
you
you know maybe this was a glib answer
but that question stuck with me and i
have been asking that of myself and of
others
since that time
we need to know what we want to do in
the world
you know we're not educated to that
nobody in school don't you think that
this is a smart question
hello
you are six what do you like to do
what do you think you want to do what
would you like to do today you're eight
hi what's going on oh you like the
painting what would you like to do today
you know you have to ask this question
of yourself throughout life
what is it that you want to do
you're here on the planet
for a purpose
you know there is something you can do
that is better than anyone else and your
job is to find it and nobody's been
helping us do that
so
i took that question and presented it in
the book to others this is the most
important question can you answer this
question and you only have answered this
question when you ask it of yourself and
your heart beats
you have to keep asking until something
moves and you something is visceral
this is why this word came out of the
teaching because
when you're teaching actors you have to
give them a technique it's very
important if you don't offer a really
firm technique
you're not teaching you're not offering
anything but beyond technique what what
what makes what takes a a good actor a
serviceable actor to a great actor to to
an inspirational actor what is that lift
off
well it's inspiration it's when
something comes in
that
wakes the artist up and that he can
follow and he can trust
and
he knows that something exciting has
come in he knows that it's inspirational
because his heart beats a little faster
because he's even nervous about it
because sometimes when that comes in and
you get that kind of a hit
you're anti you i do i can't do that
that's too scary you know it's scary no
all of those
feelings those visceral feelings the
heartbeat
the stomach turn
all of those things are indicators that
you are going in the right path
follow that path
so
you see what you want you ask questions
until you get that then you clarify this
is the direction i want to go and this
is what i want in life this is what i
meant now you can take the steps
you know then they're revealed you know
if you if you want to be an actor then
you're going to take certain steps to
get to be an actor but
i want to be an actor
lots of people say i want to be an actor
but
unless your heart beats
on i want to be an actor
you're just maybe fantasizing about
being an actor
you know your heart has to be you have
to have a purpose for it whether it's
painting whether it's acting whether
it's carving small animals and
leaving them in trees for people to find
like boo radley you know whatever your
bliss is whatever your
you you know because it moves in you
think people like the idea of what being
an actor is oh yeah yeah because we you
know we have two parts to us
we have the ego the personality and we
have the spirit which is we are
energetic beings in bodies
but we have nothing supporting us in
that way there's nothing to support that
there's no education you know it
flows over into religion
well it has nothing to do with religion
religion is something else you know it's
something you know
they've kind of failed us religions it
got a little dogmatic and people went
really
so people want to find that in
themselves you know if we looked at all
the religious you know
books and all
everything and
we were told
nobody can tell you this you can read
these books but they're just inspiration
you know nobody can tell you what they
are that would be beautiful wouldn't
that be beautiful if you read the bible
if you read the quran if you read these
beautiful books and and only you could
answer to them this is what we need only
you we need to listen to ourselves and
we don't have any concept as to how to
do that so actors
back to the question
you know a lot of actors personality
we're looking at nothing but actors
actors are running all of advertising
you know and
everything is yeah i want to be an actor
i think i want to be an actor i want
people to look at me like that
that's one answer that comes from you
know the ego and i want to be admired i
want to be looked at and you know that's
natural we all want that and if we
didn't get it as children which is in
many many cases we're going to seek it
elsewhere
but in act there are actors who it moves
in them because their mission in life
is to reveal the human condition
that's what acting is it's revealing the
human condition and i liken um actors to
magicians
because they're creating life before
your very eyes and when they get it
right
you leave
your little life and you enter their
storytelling you know when an actor
enters that realm and they're living it
before your very eyes as if it were a
parallel
universe a parallel life right there and
we know that everybody knows that they
have a thermometer they go that guy's
really in there or that guy's really
acting and the guy who's acting we enjoy
it it's entertainment but the guy who's
elevated the guy who's living it the guy
who is dared to enter that
you know that guy is working out of
inspiration that guy is a magician and
when he's working we leave we leave our
little life and we enter his life and we
take a little vacation
from our own life
and and then when he's done
you know we admire that and we think
well
if he can control all of that maybe i
can do a little better with my own life